hola de nuevo la idea este vídeo es
comparar los precios de los bonos y ver
por qué se comportan de manera opuesta o
se mueven de manera opuesta a la tasa de
interés entonces los precios de los
bonos contra la tasa de interés la tasa
de interés y ese va a ser el tema de
este vídeo y antes de entrar a un
análisis detallado y muy locochón
lo primero que quiero que analicemos es
qué es lo que va a pasar con el precio
del bono si tenemos un a3 center es
mayor o menor es decir en que se
modifica el precio de un bono si
nosotros cambiamos la tasa de interés
por lo tanto este va a ser mi bono y
supongamos que es un bono que le vamos a
comprar a la compañía llamada a a la
compañía a iu pero si lo podemos comprar
te media de gobierno a la tesorería que
nosotros que hemos probado suponer que
si lo compramos a la compañía
y este bono tiene un precio de mil pesos
y además tiene una fecha de vencimiento
de dos años con esto es lo que vamos a
empezar a trabajar ahora bien también
necesitamos una tasa interés para ver
cuánto es lo que vamos a ganar por lo
tanto supongamos que este bono tiene una
tasa interés
del 10 por cada cupón anualmente
mientras que los pagos van a ser semi
anuales esto quiere decir que si
nosotros juntamos el 10% anualmente que
son 100 pesos los pagos nos van a ser
cada 6 meses entonces vamos a dibujar
una línea del tiempo para ver qué es lo
que va a pasar este es el día de hoy
aquí tenemos nuestra línea del tiempo
hasta aquí llega y entonces en la fecha
de vencimientos dos años por lo tanto el
final de esta línea del tiempo para
hacer dos años la mitad son doce meses
aquí tenemos dieciocho meses y aquí
tenemos seis meses ahora bien recuerden
siempre que datacenter exceda anualmente
y si lo calculamos el 10% de 1000 son
100 pesos sin embargo son 100 pesos
anualmente como los pagos son semi
anuales es decir cada seis meses tenemos
que dividir estos 100 pesos en dos pagos
por lo tanto los primeros seis meses voy
a obtener 50 pesos no voy a poner otro
color para que se vea que es dinero
color de dinero que es amarillo muy bien
y voy a poner aquí 50 pesos en 12 meses
van a ser otros 50 pesos desde cuenta
50 pesos 50 pesos suman 100 pesos en un
año en 18 meses tengo otros 50 pesos y
en dos años tengo 50 pesos más los mil
pesos del dinero que le preste a la
compañía es decir el dinero del bono y
bueno vamos a suponer que este escenario
te parece perfecto estamos aquí parados
el día de hoy y vemos este bono lo
emiten y nosotros lo compramos compramos
el bono de la compañía el cual vale mil
pesos y a mí me parece una buena tasa de
interés para este nivel de riesgo en una
fecha de vencimiento de dos años del 10%
es decir yo tengo el 10 por ciento de
interés anual durante mis siguientes dos
años entonces aquí tengo el precio del
bono o el valor nominal que en la fecha
en la que emitieron el bono es de mil
pesos por lo tanto lo voy a escribir
aquí mil pesos y estamos de acuerdo con
todo lo demás es decir que vamos a
recibir después de dos años mil
doscientos pesos ya con la tasa de
interés del 10 por ciento de interés
anual muy bien ahora vamos a modificar
un poco esto supongamos que justo en el
momento en el que lo compró un momentito
después cambia la tasa de interés
bueno vamos a ir un poquito más
realistas tal vez no en ese momento tal
vez un día después compro yo el bono y
un día después sube la tasa de interés
entonces voy a escribir con un nuevo
color y la tasa de interés va a subir la
tasa de interés suben bueno ahora la
pregunta es qué es lo que va a pasar con
el precio y bueno vamos a suponer que
para esta compañía el interés sube
porque el riesgo aumenta entonces va a
aumentar supongamos al 15% es mucho pero
vamos a aumentar las al 15% entonces
vamos a esperar un 15 por ciento de
interés anual es decir la tasa de
interés va a aumentar del 10% al 15%
esperamos 15 por ciento de la tasa de
interés y bueno ahora vamos a vernos un
poco drásticos y vamos a suponer que tú
necesitas efectivo así que no puedes
esperar hasta la fecha de vencimiento de
los dos años para que te regresen tu
dinero entonces todo acudes a mí me
dices oye sal es que necesito efectivo
no puedo esperar estos dos años para
para que llegue la fecha de vencimiento
me recibiesen mi dinero entonces vengo a
ofrecerte este bono cuánto estás
dispuesto a pagar por este bono y
entonces es que yo te voy a decir qué
voy a tener que pagar menos de 1000
pesos porque para este bono se espera
una tasa de interés del 15 por ciento
mientras que en el bono dice que te van
a pagar la tasa de interés del 10% por
lo tanto yo no puedo pagarte estos mil
pesos necesito pagarte algo menor de sus
mil pesos vamos a hacer las matemáticas
después pero lo que quiero que veas
escribiente puedo pagar esos mil pesos y
por lo tanto te voy a pagar algo menor
entonces vamos a escribirlo y bueno
solamente por ahora quiero crear la
intuición en la siguiente pantalla que
vamos a ver en este vídeo vamos a ver
todas las matemáticas que nos rodean
entonces si el interés sube en este caso
estamos esperando el 15% por lo tanto el
precio del bono tiene que bajar vamos a
escribirlo el precio va a bajar o dicho
de otra manera el bono tendrá que tener
un descuento del precio en su valor
nominal
el bono tendrá que tener un descuento
del precio que aparece en su valor
nominal que aparece en su valor nominal
muy bien ya lo tenemos escrito aquí
ahora vamos a ver el siguiente caso ya
entendimos qué es lo que pasa si la tasa
de interés sube ahora bien si la tasa de
interés baja es decir va a pasar lo
contrario al ejemplo de arriba si la
tasa de interés baja qué es lo que va a
suceder con el precio entonces vamos a
suponer que la tasa de interés baja y
esperamos solamente un 5% en esta tasa
de interés puede algún motivo del cual
no vamos a filosofar ahorita la tasa de
interés cambia del 10% al 5% es decir
baja bueno si esto sucede y pasa la
misma situación no necesitas vender este
bono yo te voy a decir bueno este bono
me interesa pero si por un bono que
tiene el 10% de tasa de interés anual
voy a pagar mil pesos o aproximadamente
mil pesos y tú me ofreces este bono
cuando en realidad se espera una tasa de
5% de interés entonces a mí me conviene
comprarte lo que le voy a comprar a un
precio más alto por lo tanto voy a pagar
más
el valor nominal de este bono es decir
el precio va a subir y a estos bonos
cuyo valor es mayor que el valor nominal
se le conocen como bonos con prima bonos
con prima muy bien entonces ya tenemos
los dos posibles casos si la tasa de
interés sube entonces el precio baja y
por lo tanto habrá un descuento en su
valor a comparación del valor nominal y
en dado caso de que la tasa de interés
baje entonces el precio va a subir y en
este caso tenemos un bono con prima y
espero que hasta aquí haya creado
bastante intuición porque jugamos
bastante con puras ideas intuitivas
ahora sí vamos a meterle un poco de
matemáticas un poco de precios y vamos a
ver qué es lo que pasa entonces
primeramente voy a hablar de un bono 010
o un cupón cero es aquel bono tal que se
cumple la siguiente propiedad muy
importante después de la fecha de
vencimiento te van a pagar lo que dice
en el valor nominal de este bono es
decir si el bono está estipulado que
después de dos años vamos a suponer que
nuestra fecha de vencimiento son dos
años después de dos años que se vendió
este bono
sea quien sea no importa pero sea quien
sea el propietario o el titular de este
bono va a recibir mil pesos eso lo vamos
a ver con la línea del tiempo para que
quede mucho más claro como tenemos este
bono cero lo que sí sabemos es que
después de dos años el propietario va a
recibir mil pesos y date cuenta como no
he hablado del valor inicial de este
bono eso va a depender de la tasa de
interés
ahora bien vamos a hablar de las tasas
de interés en el día 1 que es lo que va
a pasar supongamos que en el día 1
tenemos una tasa interés del 10 por
ciento anualmente recuerden que las
tasas de interés se dan anualmente
entonces el primer día tenemos la tasa
de interés del 10% y ahora si pongan
mucha atención porque vamos a utilizar
las matemáticas porque ahora lo que
quiero saber es cuál es el precio en el
día 1 bueno lo que sí sabemos es que nos
van a regresar mil pesos después de dos
años y que tenemos una tasa de interés
del 10 por ciento anualmente por lo
tanto muy precio inicial le voy a poner
la letra p la voy a multiplicar esta p
por 1.10 y esto porque quiere decir que
a este precio lo vamos a multiplicar
después de un año por su valor total más
del 10 por ciento de interés anual y
como son dos años entonces tengo que
multiplicar por 1.10 y después por 1.10
eso quiere decir que cada año vamos a
obtener el 10 por ciento de interés
anual muy bien pero ahora para saber
cuánto es el precio necesitamos una
igualdad product and te lo voy a igualar
al valor que tenemos después de los 2
años es decir a mil pesos y ahora si
podemos despejar a pepe pues tenemos una
ecuación muy sencilla de resolver pero
por 1.10 por 1.10 es igual a 1000 esto
quiere decir que por 1.10 elevado al
cuadrado me tenía que dar los mil pesos
del valor de la fecha de vencimiento de
este bono cero entonces vamos a
escribirlo pd que multiplica a 1.1 que
es lo mismo que 1.10 elevado al cuadrado
es igual a 1000 y si pasamos dividiendo
en 1.1 elevado al cuadrado me queda que
p es igual a 1000 entre 1.1 elevado al
cuadrado que por cierto 1.1 elevado al
cuadrado es 1.21 y mil entre 1.21 bueno
ya no está tan sencillo entonces para
eso creo que voy a ocupar mejor la
calculadora y para que vaya quedando muy
claro lo que sí les quiero comer
es que el precio inicial lo estamos
sacando dividiendo a mil pesos entre uno
más la tasa de interés es decir el valor
inicial más la tasa de interés elevado
al cuadrado porque son dos años y
cuántos esto mil dividido entre 1.1
elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que 826
punto 44 pesos es decir el valor inicial
del día 1 del primer día en que
compramos
este bono cero fue de 826 pesos
no estoy redondeando para no hacernos
más bolas pero lo que sí quiero que tú
te des cuenta es lo siguiente en un
inicio nosotros pagamos 826 pesos a una
tasa de interés del 10% anual y pasados
dos años entonces nos van a regresar mil
pesos ahora la pregunta sería qué va a
pasar si la tasa interés aumenta así que
vamos a suponer que el día siguiente la
tasa de interés aumenta y bueno al día
siguiente para que no afecte
dramáticamente las matemáticas en más si
no lo quieren ver así mejor el segundo
siguiente en el segundo siguiente la
tasa de interés aumenta que sabe por qué
pero
y aumentó hasta el 15% lo va a escribir
aquí la tasa de interés aumenta al 15%
en el siguiente segundo para que nos
veamos muy exactos en nuestra fecha de
vencimiento después de dos años ahora la
pregunta va a ser qué va a pasar con el
precio el precio que vamos a pagar de
transcurrido un segundo va a aumentar o
va a disminuir y bueno pues ha sido la
misma ecuación tendríamos mil dividido
entre 1.15 porque aumentó nuestra tasa
de interés 1.15 elevado al cuadrado y
esto lo podemos hacer otra vez en la
calculadora para ver cuánto va a variar
nuestro precio entonces mil vamos a
dividirlo entre 1.15 elevado al cuadrado
1000 dividido entre 1.15 porque teníamos
el 15% de la tasa de interés elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 756 punto 14 lo
podemos redondear en 756 en el caso de
que la tasa de interés aumente y de ese
cuento de algo la tasa de interés
aumentó del 10 al 15 por ciento y él
disminuyó y es justo lo que yo les
comentaba en la otra pantalla aumentó la
tasa de interés y por lo tanto el precio
disminuyó y bueno para acabar todo este
análisis y corroborar que el caso
contrario también es cierto qué pasa si
la tasa de interés baja vamos a suponer
que la tasa de interés baja al 5% y
entonces cuál sería el precio que
tendríamos que pagar
supongamos también que tenemos la misma
fecha de vencimiento y entonces vamos a
calcularlo el precio va a ser igual pues
a 1000 dividido entre 1 punto y ahora
cambio la tasa interés es 1.05 porque la
tasa de interés es del 5% elevado al
cuadrado y vamos a calcular los 1000
entre 1.05 elevado al cuadrado y debe de
aumentar vamos a ver cuánto nos sale
esto es igual a 907 pesos el precio va a
ser igual a 907 pesos lo que quiere
decir que si la tasa de interés baja por
lo tanto el precio va a aumentar justo
lo que habíamos supuesto y lo que
habíamos concluido en la pantalla
anterior
interés aumenta del 10 al 15 por ciento
entonces pasamos el precio de 826 pesos
a 756 pesos el precio disminuye mientras
que si la tasa de interés baja del 10 al
15% el precio va a aumentar espero que
les haya sido útil toda esta información